ha here we go against mr. Allah gasps
he's got 2,600 that's good news the
higher the rating the better yeah let's
see how his place as usual stuff and
i'll play my usual stuff don't mind that
position here much it's very equal ish
but if you draw against 2610 it's ok so
over here 24
yeah it's a typical boring position you
get against him every time let's just
make sure not to screw up something and
see that we can make a draw here I know
that's a bit bit cynical but this is
this is what it is he always plays like
that so what to do let's get this into
the game
main thing is to stay to not fall behind
on the clock this is very important um
yeah maybe this one all you have to be
alert yeah he's always trying he is
trying little things it's not like he's
shuffling around and not doing anything
ever if you do something stupid naive he
will try try things check yeah so you
got this this ending not much going on
but am i doing him
mmm there's something that I can try at
that same and I probably not yet I mean
he's got that isolated porn but there is
some very little and to be done him
cannot put any pressure let's say on
that porn it's not not happening is it
drawing a five and before maybe edits
that's possible that's actually possible
I have to be cautious a bit not to be
too passive here which sometimes happens
them if you have a position that is
basically yeah where nothing happens you
can easily get into a mode that is too
passive and don't want that I don't want
that him hmm hey for this before before
there's a form yeah I'm not playing this
well I've get I've given em I've given
in some some hope see I'm definitely
okay don't want to play rook situ in the
first place
check okay let's push him a little bit
back him
and the easiest is probably to just stay
here
I didn't play that well he's got
something absolutely i mean probably not
for real but he can pretend to do things
ha ha oh wow game drive that doesn't
happen too often I don't know anyway
yeah I just I'm just okay with gaining a
couple of points and playing the
Superdog positions um I think is in
order to beat them and I need to play
sharper that's totally clear of it I
really don't know exactly how to do it
against his kind of opening rabbit one I
tried the Ottawa key stuff but it didn't
work out simply it didn't work out so um
yeah what I'm trying to do is to players
to just play his game and to make make
those drawers just by playing solidly um
doing nothing basically which is a
winning plane in terms of points it
really is i am currently the statistics
or nice is CR not working but I've drawn
the vast majority of the recent games
and and i won I think one game even okay
so um I'm definitely gaining points with
this kind of play it is a little bit
cynical but did yeah I really don't know
what else to do to be honest am I mean I
could theoretically speaking prepare
against his against his openings and try
to work out something to get active
aggressive play against his repertoire
but I mean really if I've got time to
work on stuff for my own shares yeah I'm
not going to do it to investor I'm not
investing it in an opening repertoire
installed cast yeah anyway it was a
correct draw and I'm reasonably okay
with that thanks for watching